now it's time for the uplifted eight
where we share stories that will bring
some joy to your day i got jamie yucas
laughing in the commercial break we got
david bagner back for us what do we got
today i always say if only you could
hear what we say
i love the uplift today's story is about
a little boy in massachusetts getting a
very special gift
it's not
just so much
thank you you got your own song that is
nine-year-old sam getting his very own
sewing machine for his birthday so the
video went viral on tick tock hitting
more than two and a half million views
sam loves to sew and last month he
actually went to a sewing camp where he
was the only boy so far he has made
dresses bags and even hair scrunchies
his parents aaron and mj say that sam
has been bullied because he likes to sew
and paint his nails
his dad said that reading the supportive
comments on the video with sam has been
miraculous for him sam says he is most
proud of a dress that he made for his
cousin
at sewing camp and sam i got something
for you my man
nails
are in yes i love it there you go sam
paint them buddy
yeah my fiance's son loves to do it too
he's got a little rock star nail like
star on there you know i mean i think
just who cares and here's a fun fact
about me i learned to sew in middle
school and i've been doing it ever since
stuff and sold it at school so sam keep
doing your thing yes just be you that's
right scrunchies though i would think a
scrunchie is a pretty high level thing
to sell i didn't know you could sew a
scrunchie yeah it's all like all the
curves on everything yeah shout out i
love when guys talk about some friends
right here at the table so get yourself
some good nails sam it's all in